bitcoin is a decentralized
cryptocurrency which is immune from
government corruption you would be naive
to think that one day they wouldn't come
for your money you know we're hearing
cbdc so your viewers child cbdc's our
central bank digital currencies and they
are essentially cryptocurrencies but
they are centralized they have full
control central banks have full control
over that so the scary thing here is
that this is actually programmable money
so charles if you say you know i don't
want to get that second shot or i don't
want to get that third booster then the
government can say well that money that
you're getting paid we're going to
program it so you can't actually spend
it inside certain shops to protect you
of course
uh and you've talked about this you know
what central banks are trying to do
feels like they're doing carrot and
stick right we've heard about
regulations and banning that got a lot
of pressure so now they're saying well
maybe we'll join it is there a chance
that they will be able to usurp this
movement in one way or another
well i don't think bitcoin can be banned
we've seen what's happened in china for
example and that has only helped the
network it has further secured the
network there's a lot of concerns that
bitcoin is centralized in china the
mining is centralized in china but now
because they banded in china
miners have then started to redistribute
to kazakhstan the usa and that therefore
actually helps further secure the
network bitcoin is a decentralized
cryptocurrency so whatever the usa does
whatever happens it will still thrive
somewhere else in the world i just want
to take you to nigeria as an example so
the cbn the central bank of nigeria they
became extremely hostile towards bitcoin
throughout 2021 and as a result it
actually had a positive effect on the
price bitcoin started trading at around
80 000
um in in nigeria and then peer-to-peer
trading actually increased by 27 percent
now that's incredible because that was
actually the goal of bitcoin to remove
the
it's so amazing uh cryptocurrency
bitcoin bringing the sort of economic
freedom that governments have promised
but really rarely have ever delivered on
in history uh lan thank you very much
it's great meeting you and great talking
hopefully we'll have you again real soon
uh meanwhile folks this